is it worth upgrading to the brand new
Apple watch series 8 from the series 7.
like I'm going to show you in this video
by comparing everything between them or
should you rather just get the brand new
second generation Apple watch SE well
I'm going to show you all the
differences in terms of everything like
the displays the features the specs the
pricing and which one I honestly
recommend for different use cases so
let's go ahead and start unboxing both
of these new models right here there you
go this is the Starlight SE and there
you go we have this nice little paper
that you could just rip open and I'm
already seeing a difference compared to
the original SE now before I get this
band on I'm going to set this aside and
let's unbox the brand new series 8 Apple
watch and this is the midnight color of
the series eight it looks quite nice
let's take it out of that paper wow
that's a nice
dark midnight color now before I get
these set up with the Apple watch bands
on I do want to talk about the pricing
and the different case sizes as you can
see we have the smaller 40 millimeter
size of the se2 and we have the larger
45 millimeter sizes for the series 7 and
the eight now the series 8 starts at
3.99 but it's 30 bucks more for this 45
millimeter size and the series 7. you
can actually get for as low as 270
dollars online we'll leave some links
below which makes this quite a good deal
now in terms of the actual case
differences I'm looking at the series 7
and the eight and I am not seeing any
differences in terms of the backs and
the sensors I do see the difference in
color of course we have the nice blue
whereas the midnight blue is really
really dark which looks pretty nice but
the differences in the back you don't
really see at all and that's because
they're essentially the same Apple watch
we really only have the brand new crash
detection feature which is also on the
se2 and of course we have the new
temperature sensors that are really only
meant for women's cycle tracking with
ovulation estimation but in reality we
can't test it out of course and also
because it takes five days of Baseline
readings just to get that feature to
finally start working for the ladies out
there so in reality the differences
between the series 7 and the eight are
extremely minimal which is why a lot of
the guys out there might want to just
get the series 7 but moving on to the
new se2 of course we have the smaller
case size but Apple did say that it has
a new nylon back which you can see right
there and that's just a fancy word for
plastic because this is plastic right
here instead of this ceramic backs that
these two have and I think the original
SC also had the ceramic back but in
reality the people going for the SE
watch espec for the new 250 dollar price
tag they're not going to care if it's a
plastic back it's not really going to
matter and the nice thing about the se2
in terms of pricing is the cellular
upgrade is only 50 dollars more on this
model so it's going to be three hundred
dollars for cellular compared to the
series 8 where it's a hundred dollar
upgrade for cellular so you're paying at
least five hundred dollars for that
model but of course you could get this
series 7 with cellular discounted on
Amazon right now and one last little
difference that I can see right here is
that the SE has the second generation
Optical heart sensor so it has a
different design compared to the much
nicer and newer one on the series 7 and
8 which also have the special ECG
sensors now before I tell you about the
software difference and a surprise
change by Apple that we didn't expect
that might actually make you want to get
the series eight let's throw some bands
on here now what I have right here are a
couple of really nice and elegant
leather bands from our sponsor long
vidon now these two are made out of high
quality top grain bovine leather in this
nice crocodile embossed pattern this one
on the left is the Cayman light for 59
it's in the midnight black color and we
also have the whiskey Brown Cayman for
89 and the nice thing about this one is
that it comes with the butterfly clasp
compared to the ardalon buckle on the
Cayman light and on the bottom they also
come with this really nice bovine suede
leather and right now you can use a
coupon code maxtec 15 for 15 off long
vidon's bands in the description below
now getting back to the Apple watches
before I talk about the SE I first have
to talk about the differences with the
series 7 and the eight now as far as
software differences we used to have
brand new Apple watch faces on the new
models like for example the series 8
however with watch OS 9 Apple changed it
up and you can now get all of the watch
faces available people on basically any
watch since the series 4 I believe and
even the Nike watch faces are no longer
exclusive to the Nike Apple watch models
you can get all of that with the series
7 so there's no real difference there
now however Apple did make a sneaky move
recently by adding Bluetooth 5.3 to the
series 8 and the se2 whereas they used
to be 5.0 so they made that change so
the series 7 does have 5.0 now this
Bluetooth 5.3 actually matter well it is
if you're going to be getting another
device that actually has Bluetooth 5.3
so if you're getting the new iPhone 14
then you'll be taking advantage of the
new features in terms of the lower
battery life usage the better bandwidth
potentially longer range better audio
quality for example if you're getting
the new airpods Pro 2 which also have
Bluetooth 5.3 now if you are not getting
the iPhone 14 or the new airpods Pro 2
then you're not gonna have any any
difference and you'll be just fine with
the series 7 that has Bluetooth 5.0 and
the same thing kind of goes with the new
crash detection feature on the series 8
because if you're already getting an
iPhone 14 then it's not really going to
matter because those iPhones have crash
detection built in so it's not going to
matter if you have the series 7 or the
eight and then of course the series 8
also has the ovulation tracking so if
you care about that as a lady then you
might want to get the series 8 but to be
honest if those things don't really
matter to you and you can get the series
7 for a really good deal then I'll just
go for the series 7. and now that we
have the series 7 out of the way let's
compare the new series 8 with the se2
now the biggest difference you can see
right away is that the SE does not have
the always on display as you can see you
can tap them to turn both of them on and
then when you close them there you go
you have the always on display which is
a nice luxury feature so you can still
see some of the information section on
your Apple watch now what really
impresses me about the se2 apart from
the very low entry level price of 250
and 300 for the cellular model compared
to over 500 for this larger size with
cellular is that the SE comes with a lot
of the nice features like the car crash
detection it comes with 32 gigs of
storage it comes with Bluetooth 5.3 the
same S8 chip which is actually 20 faster
than the previous SE which had the S5
chip so that's a really nice bonus
however there are quite a few things
that are lacking first of all you can
only get the aluminum case with the SE
and either midnight Starlight or silver
whereas the series 8 gets the additional
product red color and the stainless
steel models in either gold silver or
graphite and on top of that the se2 is
lacking a couple of the health features
like the blood oxygen sensor the ECG
cardiogram app of course the cycle track
attacking with ovulation estimation with
the temperature sensors it also lacks
the fast charging feature which could be
a big deal if you use the sleep tracking
the series 8 also gets the U1 Ultra
wideband ship for better location
tracking and it supports the 5 gigahertz
Wi-Fi band for faster downloading of
apps and then finally the series 8 also
has ip6x dust resistance so with that
said you can see that the extra cost of
the series 8 is well warranted with all
those extra features as well as the
always on display so in reality even
though it is a little bit more expensive
I would say that if you're going to be
wearing this for the next two three four
five years then it is worth spending the
extra money but if you're on a really
tight budget or if you're buying this as
a gift or maybe even for your kid
because you want to buy cellular which
is only fifty dollars more if you want
to set them up with using an Apple Watch
instead of having to buy them an iPhone
then I'd say that the SC2 2 is an
incredible value but personally I'd say
that a discounted Series 7 is probably
the best way to go because you're saving
that money and you're getting a lot of
those nice features so hopefully this
video helps you decide if you should
upgrade or which model you should buy
and if it did click the circle above to
subscribe and definitely check out one
of those two videos right there
including our iPhone 14 pro Max versus
13 Pro Max comparison video thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
thank you